most famous person in your family I got
a lot of people with famous Jimmy Butler
if you could only eat food for an entire
year I think everyone knows this it
would be pancakes we have to mix it up
some gluten-free no sugar there's no
syrup definitely pancakes what is your
favorite NBA Finals performance you've
ever seen the 2019 NBA champion Toronto
Raptors if your teammates could describe
you in one word I will not be able to
say that because this is a kid-friendly
platform what would your dream job be if
you weren't playing in the NBA if I
wasn't playing the NBA the best dad that
I could possibly be which I'm trying to
be now